ariana grande seems so in love and it
shows in this rare look at life with her
hubby dalton gomez
[Music]
the couple is dressed to the nines ari
rocks a black dress in heels as she
holds on to her man who's looking classy
in a gray suit in another shot the two
topped the moment with a kiss simply
adding a heart emoji as the caption
i feel your love every day now the
seventh ring singer is known for
dropping small glimpses of their life
together since tying the knot last may
like this intimate photo ari shared last
august and weeks before that the song
just wished her husband a happy birthday
showing a pic of the two in amsterdam
calling the real estate agent my baby my
husband my best friend it's a very
exciting thing for us and back in
october ari bonded over married life
with long time friend ed sheeran as he
joined as mega mentor on the voice while
she was a coach last season i'm so
excited you're here hi nice to see you
and you're married now i am you as well
yeah we had a kid that is so exciting
now there's no kids for ari and dalton
just yet but a source told et at the
time they said i do the two are ecstatic
and looking forward to their future
together quote ariana is dalton's first
priority in everything that they do and
he really values her and shows it ariana
loves that dalton is super chill and how
understanding he is of her do whatever
you want
whatever you want whatever feels natural
be yourself
ari won't be the only one enjoying
married life in her family her brother
frankie grande got engaged last june to
boyfriend hail leon and expect the
grammy winner to be part of the ceremony
frankie spilled all the deets to e.t on
his upcoming nuptials i want a big
wedding i do it's going to be like
around like 100. i feel like i feel like
covet is definitely kind of like
right-sized like in my mind like the
invitation list you know and so it'll be
like around 100 people which will be a
lovely a lovely affair you know what is
ari your sister's position in the
wedding um well she will be in my
wedding party yes yes
it was like a maiden of honor what we
were doing with that you know we haven't
even like i haven't even set up like
what the structure of my wedding party
is going to be like like if i'm the
bride and hail's the groom if it's the
bridal party and the groomsmen like we
don't even know um but um she and dalton
will obviously be in the wedding party
so i'm very very excited it's kind of
that's super fun to be like newlyweds
together exactly and it's like i don't
even have like i don't have a best man
like i don't know if that's what i'm
supposed to do you know what i'm saying
it's like we're just we're still the
early phases is basically what i'm
saying to you but we'll we'll figure it
out